no one really no one with the internet in
germany has so far
earned as much money as this person he has become a
multiple billionaire with a
jockey free so his
father-in-law was looking at money profit has has made
everyone want to become a billionaire
that doesn't work all that probably
the most important challenger for
once  worldwide he empowers us all
to build a shop and the guy behind it
is a university dropout from
koblenz about canada air is called tobias wuttke
and here is my conversation with
heike thank you very
much for having me here
from harrison that they say i have to that
's a problem  sometimes my brain
will give me all the english
answers and then i have to translate them in my
head and sometimes it sounds
completely computer so
please excuse company
you've been
around for a while now about half a life can be
exactly i'm 18 years here i  I'm almost
done so that means I have
most of the time my e  spent adult life and
canada and from in germany
what you read is always koblenz
really core koblenz yes exactly i grew
up in downtown koblenz
and
lived a bit somewhere else i lived in nuremberg
a bit from my
apprenticeship but outside of that i grew up in some koblenz  I'm
binsch grandchild and
[music]
I think somehow the
German universities were good
enough that they could get out of there like you
but the choice is you did your
most important years of training at
Siemens I've seen it depends
on the training that  was
the time at school was relative i am so
easy the children deserve the school
not really good device right
environment was i have i have i was a
teenager in 90 years and
had a computer he was much
much more interesting than the
ones they were  the six seven hours
you spent there day at school
ha  t mainly took
care of my own training during the time
in the podcast digital pioneer from
vodafone, which i like to mention here so often and
in the month of june it
was all about start-ups
personalities start-up
stories that’s why christoph buseck was a guest  for example the an die burg
schlögl founder of witz and scribbles at
this big start up festival in
munich the hendrik gottschalk from bed
bath a solution in the area of augmented reali
y and last but not least the christian bitze
my longtime partner colleague homer
bart christian bitzer im silic
n  valley lives god for us makes
his own podcast and, so to speak,
tells startup stories first-hand from silicon valley has interesting consequences in this respect
club subscribes to the podcast digital
pioneers from vodafone
as is well known, nowhere can you
point out podcasts as well as in other
podcasts along the way  the brief reference to
the facebook update  a podcast from
facebook about the entire facebook
ecosystem the podcast project channel for
the podcast is divided into two parts,
the format of the facebook marketing
talk includes interviews with the jin choi and
so the director trade media tech
telco energy is called the jin for the German-speaking area
choi talks to
exciting personalities from the
entire facebook ecosystem and the
second format is called the facebook
marketing experts there,
employees from facebook in germany talk
very practically about
news and new tips and tricks
on the platform itself, both of which are available
at the end in the channel dass  facebook update also
channel in the sense of podcast
channel it's best to listen there
exciting people as guests at the jin
choi most recently the theater opera soon the
julia bush by cherry all
information at fb.me / facebook marketing
and then you left school, so to speak
, high school there  they don't even have
a tenth grade yet
in the ninth grade we
had an internship
week i did my company for a few weeks
which belonged to siemens nixdorf in
koblenz and that was a revelation for
you to see at all like him there were
people who were paid for it with
computers  to make the same comb that
i then made at home otherwise that would be
exactly that i wanted i wanted to do it
myself all day i.e.
it was clear to me at that point that i would
try to apply and i got those
who also got the trainee position
and after the tenth grade
I started asking then yes then I'll be all
more I that will come soon but let's
continue again for a moment and
then you
somehow found it to believe that you once said that in the
park that had inspired you a lot
at siemens
itself but his manager so to speak
, where that is, who somehow put you on
the right track, that's right,
i have it there  nn fantastic so quite a
lot of fantastic people who
worked there but some young people
saw me then
rock me under his wings a bit they say so
nicely and noticed that
I was a bit specialized
like an ant egypt  now
i've programmed my whole childhood
and
disassembled and assembled computers and i missed
everything that had nothing to do with it
at the time and it
showed me that life is also a bit
more diverse and
but if you have a specialization
then you also have a bit more
time to learn other things like
you have to learn and the next few
years were incredibly important for me
to have
[music]
then it went like this it's funny
has to look back and all these
different points  to connect like that
, it all sounds so different and you
automatically go from one thing to the next
, but you're knocked out  hle of course
everything was much more difficult at the time they
were that was
only at the end of the 90s when i just
noticed again that they were
coming like that that the
internet would become of course how
important but then of course the people who
looked at it from the inside
earlier and said that
some of the companies are being built how
has nothing to do with reality at
all then of course it all fell apart completely
the 2001 and 2000 they were
special doublette time was really
a roller coaster  what was the time for you
when you went to the usa or to
canada because of love as
the saying goes met a canadian while snowboarding
met a bit of dirt days
living so exactly so that was
another kind of story that somehow
if  looking back, of course, it
looks as if it was all well planned in a way
, i but that i met 400
we didn't we
lived in germany
and didn't take part in studies and when
she went back to
kader i said that sounds like saying now
i'll do that too and then
it went on like that with exactly that and
then later i liked the shop  stayed
here and that there is also
a whole kind of so fun fact first
then until recently until a few
years ago it was more or less if you read it like
that with
your parents-in-law, i.e. with the parents of a friend at the time then also
lived at home with you  basically yes that i
think now for five years that
means the first yes the first twelve
years as i lived it green in canada
now there are also incredibly great
parents-in-law and that's a
crazy story we heard is
somehow now
on the move in this sphere and  lives with his
parents-in-law that's really almost
too good well i have i
forgot
56 years from the from the children's room
from my from my  he wife
was our praying then i was writing
and there i had my laptop with
it so it went digital partie follows
now important yes but then
she had the between those so you went to
canada and stopover
at night wants this model wants
episode  where you
tried to sell snowboards, so to speak, in
a self-built webshop and
then learned via the webshop what
it takes to build workshops and to
tell her correctly, that was
super interesting, so for me
it was like I said  I said yes
, it was in 2001 that the
dotcom bubble
burst and
the funny thing was that so many of them made
this film so of course it was
20 years ago but that's so many of
these companies back then were e-commerce
companies of course they have this webcam
and pads dot com
and
that i just thought it was
2003 4 when i started to work with
110 m to the  n and I would have
thought that back then
all my problems in e-commerce were already solved.
That was a huge part of the internet
and when I built this store
I really noticed that there was
software and there were even open source
projects that you could use  could which I
also used to try
it out but the quality was really
extremely low especially for
and for entrepreneurs for entrepreneurs because
I know I have can I didn't
exist the business
somehow had to integrate into the sap
system that wasn't mine  problem one
problem was i had to set up a new
business there are completely different
categories of problems
and so i then made the software
myself because programming
one of these tools that just
moved with me in my tour blogs
and that's what i did then
I then used it a lot and
then built my own system and that
's a lot of fun g  emacht and so on
but what's really interesting was
that the
interrogator really didn't build any software and
that's what I found interesting and
while I was building the
model I realized that it really was
that I was now at this moment  more
is about what how how it works starting
a new business recordings on the internet
directly than most
other people and of course the
entrepreneurial nature of business is
a bit about what
kind of unfair advantages do you usually have in the form
of information or or where  that's true
and that's when i noticed that
programming and
having the party with nine entrepreneurs
that's what i can combine and
then i built a lot you have
to say that noda still didn't go
badly it was just that  a
project that you then or a company that
then also had a feeling for two years or something
, at least my w  perception and
guns season snowboarders think season
is over and now it's even standing
press design bankruptcy had it
shut down although it was
successful yes it's made by the same company that
's exactly what the company set you
up for me back then for the new tv
and well i know  it wasn't how much it
was me that was a
good commercial entrepreneur or how
much of it my luck had to do with it
so like I said
2005 2014 five came out that's
really not that's so that's a
lot about marketing so that  we
really have to talk about it for a moment
so that the the internet is so
different you know we have so from from
the whole web technology was that was
just the time when you could use style sheets
so before that most systems e-
mail systems had frames  used that
the list that doesn't exist anymore so
stupid chain the browser and
you can tell that google adwords was more important for marketing
that
just came out that was completely
under and under the radar at the time google was
i think they just went on the
stock market but more than
most companies didn’t have a
budget for online marketing
they bought benders twice
then decided the
internet marketing wasn't working and
then they stopped and at the time
i had my little snowboard shop
yes we were selling snowboards for
rang 40 50 percent win every now
and then and
i had a few competitors that
were into through the tower snowboards
each
click costs 16 dollars, which is much too
expensive, i uploaded a spreadsheet
with the data from every
ski resort in north america and i
was there with everyone except whistler, i think i was
the only one who had asked for these
keywords  I have I
have snowboards for 600 dollars in the evening with
50% martin for
20 cents per kli
ck is already in the late 1960s or
search engine optimized not optimally
but by getting your high school exams almost exactly
but also insane because i would have
to
build up i started a blog
that was the golden age of the
internet i also built the blog
myself  is actually a relatively short
time that is known as one of the
most popular block
systems and I wrote about it when I had
the experience to
rebuild these snowboarders but found out in the
default theme of snow jam, which
gave the depot from this blog system  there was
also a link directly to my
website which i then 33 0 1
comment like came straight after the shop
party sent later that means back
then it was a huge huge topic
but pagerank that was the authority of the
domain is a huge part of
but back then that was apple  9 and
Schoppe perfect was 8 so right on
9 that's there it was that was so
easy back then ste h  ol to use rings
and stuff like that we then it's a
very easy time and but
you still decided
to leave the beatles like business so it
would have now because not
very many people would have i know
them then  somehow they opened a big search
marketing agency and
then maybe at some point they
didn’t just have snowboards in the big shop for sporting
goods, and I would have been
different if
I included surfboards, so what could you have that
was all very profitable back then and
what was there in general at the front and early  but
you then really
decided that for the tech product, so to speak
, just wanted to help other people with the day
exactly that was that was so close that
when you have done something like this you mainly go
through your experience in the meantime
then you learn a lot about
myself and one of the things that
really
mattered to me was this this this
moment where i felt like the first potter
buys have a real monumental
assembly line in my life that can
remember everything that was i know
exactly which coffee shop i was in and
where i opened my laptop i
know what i wore that
day stuff like that that's such a man
man  man man man
man you get and entrepreneur at the
moment when you really sell something and
not when you build something and
at some point i had this experience something with such
a moment of clarity because it became
clear that that that i that is only that
can only happen once in the  so living
that's not what you get again
but what do i know can do
to help other people to have such an
experience and that's why and
then i slowly asked a few people if
i might license bishop
twer and then i have it
things just done together and i
said to help the simple people
with a software service
company atic i  that the
service was a concept but that
has changed a bit so it was
somehow the obvious
operating system of the internet
I do it so that I end up people
who are not so technical
can help themselves to
software like snow der  would and
then use that myself and then i would have
helped other people but
to have life events and yeah that's exactly
what it is now 15 years later and it
's happening to us every 50 seconds now i
think someone has their first
sale and of course that's incredible
but you have to, but at that time you were
still traveling with your partner,
so you did two parts, one
did the shopping side for the Danes
and you then
continued with the tech and product, so to speak, that was
also the early years, so to speak, because
he never was  really exactly i did
n't find out that god he
talked to the he of course talked to the
dealers and the  made the whole
inventory and so on normally
we are both from time to time but
mostly he went to the post office with the one with the slot
and to send it on
and then describe how it
goes on like that you always have one he is
the colleague went out  and then
you caught up with an old friend
from the German time, so to speak,
then more or less
came into the fabrics company
that was converted
for the service business
and then as the
halterner replay technology
company then the location is no longer
so close  and a bit before
that i got daniel to
do it i persuaded daniel to do it at the
beginning of the summer maybe in the
summer in karlsruhe that
we could work together and
then fortunately that
stayed there and it
was a bit more  work
thought so
but it really is i have so i
mean my girlfriend the  now, with whom
I have worked well for a long time, they
are of course
incredibly happy that
I brought myself to come today, that
is supposed to work wonderfully, but they
tell me from time to time that I really was
n't really honest with how
much work it was  would
and what we wanted to do there and stuff like that but that's
true and i had
no idea at all i really had i
really thought when i talked on the
phone back then that somehow you could
build summer finished picture that's of
course now there are 2000 engineers  working with
chopin friday night so
that ten years later you
really are but you are
underestimated but of course it is also the 4 4
does a lot more things so yes that
ay be the reason there is another anecd
te from the early years we also notic
d is the one with the  That was
a visa, too. He doesn't think he's allowed to
do anything else in
Kan for a while  ada apart from founding something yourself basically
well that's also that's a
story of that's also completely true
and that's also possible so
just be funny because that's just there
you notice a bit how she
really doesn't
follow the rules perfectly  the new
world are mostly converted that's
all the time is all about
work permits and that's just how
it all makes a lot of sense
but
it's a funny situation when you're
in the country and you say okay
I'm then for  as I said my
wife didn't immigrate here i did
n't have a work permit i'm that we
are i got a permanent my
little being as families
continued to break in and
you're allowed to stay there but not
work but
you can set up a company at the time so
that you can then  i said okay
then if that's what i
can do then i'll do it that's a
decision now also for the canadian
all you have di  e most valuable company in
canada in that respect it was okay
because one of the next i'm trying
to know the anecdotes nobody
can hear and read about you like this
to gather together that just bring it a bit to the chronology the
next turning point was when you traced it a
bit then  After
the years when you built this gate system
or shop system,
there was probably a
touchpoint after a Super Bowl final
where the Indianapolis Colts somehow
won, which she obviously doesn't care much about
because you're not a
football fan but you have  then
suddenly I noticed it's about shops I'm off yes
that was but it's a wonderful
story that's right at the beginning
of
a shopping free time and the
team won and that the that the
local newspaper then somehow sold a
title with the  the front page is
that you are the super bowl winner
winner and well that's what
they're supposed to be  t the evening before and that
sold the next day
19,000 50,000 which was also in one dollar
per t shirts sold the next
day and
an alarm went off that
I somehow expected the whole service train to
run almost by the
fire and still has everything
works well but then it was
clear to me that
i really had to change my projection for the hardware i had to
buy because it was really
difficult to predict what was going on in the
world and what people were going to use
things for and it was a good
story and that got us
really gave us a possible order
that that but that was
really just different than we
imagined we imagined
that it will be more like that davids knows that
we offer more people who just offer new products in
new companies on the internet directly
but  that somehow an
existing newspaper somehow exists from
one day to the next at
once der au  dienz
wants to bring together for an existing event that was a new
idea and slowly it
started like that
when you start a company like that
it's a bit like that
you really don't
know exactly how big the room is
what it is  because in general there are a lot of things
in here that's all a bit
feels a bit weird like
sometimes has a small but a
little flashlight with which you
can look around a bit and
you really have to concentrate on what
you're looking at and what you're working on  works
and what you are really trying to
understand now and all of a sudden there is a completely
different part that suddenly
opens up for which you have to
concentrate and if you
over the years you slowly
slowly slowly understand the space in which it is
located  at the beginning it is
completely unclear and that is the content of
these these touchdowns over the
years that then arise  it
was a real turning point so only then
noticed now there is actually
super bowl a lot of attention the
range of time just said and
then it's just not an entrepreneur
the suit with three snowboards or something like 5
and then slowly changing up the
vicinity  all of a sudden zack
a big company comes along and
puts pressure on and now immediately a completely different way
to earn money exactly of
course that only has huge
together huge opportunity but also
a huge problem that is
that means that i had to pay for the computer before
i  maybe
need and at the time we got
to the top was when the data center in
toronto which is a five hour drive
away from us was we
bought our service on ebay from
some accounts company went bankrupt
and he would have all of a sudden the need me that
really change so gladly
bought more for it and
have together so really that
wa  r has that was a time of the circle
has she has imagined will
be on too real and
would have to set an alarm clock in the middle of the night
was then any option of
any silva absolutely wanted to have
for the time being ended and
we would have to only wanted that
give our bid in the last few seconds
otherwise it would then like to then
we should do that too expensive and other
people would bid high that high and
so we got our machines
and then we worked it up to
capacity and in
the end it was everything  Luckily
enough, but then it was really
clear to us that we couldn't quite
imagine how people
would use the shop. That became
clearer and clearer with other flash sales that
happened later, especially in
the sneaker industry, and that just worked
everything everything so on one step after
the other and a whole quarter at the
beginning also financed by his
wife  father so he wasn't
your landlord and father-in-law anymore,
or even then only the
business center, so to speak, and then
you always had afterwards there's also such a
legendary story
that you ridden your bike lying
around and hated trying to do it somehow
to find financiers like that and ten times a
little bit of the financing starts
so we accepted a bit of
money from from from coins to
skip family friends family tools
i think it’s quite good and
that was that and then of course we used
the money from skoda will
and
so we were able to
move on relatively further with these two things, but at that time when we had to
buy really faster servers
and yes, I have to hire a few people
who would have
helped me here because I used to be
customer support & operations and the main
programmer and
I  I answered the phone and
talked to
me about everything at the same time  n
company and I have to I had
to hire someone to help with customer
support and should I say and
for that then maybe I need
a bit of capital that
tied my mum to
me my
father-in-law helped me to pay the monthly paywall
and yes i did at some point i
decided to really
accept money that was around that
time then cdu was from the company
also just to mainly because i
thought that it was all for a relatively
long time admits i thought that the
people  the idea that venture capital is
not only able to give money but
also help to find new ceo
which didn't work really well
so i could have accepted money with
it but then there were the
conditions like that we around that's the
company  to move would have to see
that i found it easy i could
that was related but i
didn't think it was a good idea  from metal from
the simple i interviewed people
for jobs i tried to
find out whether it was a good idea such a
bad idea and since 2008 it has
been 20 myself so i convinced myself
that this was not the right
company i let it be and
then  did he the the the financial crisis
started in 2008 then i thought
that the company was gone but
then unfortunately it really didn’t turn out
differently at the time several
people lost their jobs unfortunately
but then they tried their new ones
building jobs yourself platforms like
shopping partying that at the time
it suddenly worked better improve the game and
then we also became profitable
and
then we were a profitable lifestyle
company with 10 15 people for a few
years and then in 2010 I
then  um decided when it became clear to me
that we really need the
capital we can use the capital
, especially in the marketing area and
then we accepted venture
capital and then for five years
we were able to invest much, much faster rapid growth that we use we
keep our own growth
now for the first time
before that i needed all the money for payroll
and then five years later it's on again
toronto and new york went on the stock exchange at the same time
which is also not necessarily the best
idea was to do two big ones at the same
time i can’t recommend it but it
works relatively well and then
somehow five years later now
2020 will be this time of corona
and then
when it has grown enormously and yes
now it's too culture now at the time
from the market value he can be the
biggest company I'm quite sure what
I think about it and we'll say if the x
factor that would be
one in Germany too  I also have to say the biggest fan
and I looked it up
so market cap or a company on the
stock exchange is now ü  more than 100 billion that
would somehow be in the
top 5 in germany that's a lot bigger than
bmw for the listeners they're not in there they
're in the sap league there's still
very little in germany even so and
canada has that too you think
so that's a bit frightened or or
fuchsia on the plan yes
that's the right word frightened is
right as i said i don't think much
about it about the
above all the stock exchanges will continue i
think so i'm working i have
my product today i'm working with  i'm
trying to do something that's important
for small retailers i know so we
've now set ourselves a goal with
shop that we're celebrating especially
during the corona period we now want
the sea small retailers to survive this this
kroner time and maybe
even that it  they are
better off than before this
digitization of
the world of knights was incredibly
important that we see that i everyone
tag in our numbers member we have
a few businesses they put them in the
top 10 biggest business is a job available
and it's a few of them have over
a billion dollars in
sales just three of them didn't start on
shopping didn't exhaust it
those are  all new business and
can that have been made in the last ten years
and whether on the platform
and what their holders see is why
it works so incredibly well it is
multi channel business
that is really hidden in the walls of
the and online store and hold  also
facebook and instagram and so on is
all to be operated by the same system
the business
that does that exactly that is exactly what makes
me ask the question
nowadays use it today
the grow faster it works
better and that's why it is  just
fits as before very good the future
this this digital future because
we all now, so to speak, a
slap  let's
throw in a strategic question
there I was it's gone somewhere else a a
question that many probably
have this one you hear often is
always expected of course for many
companies that have just been founded smaller companies,
so to speak, aligned even if you did
n't have that much turnover  then the
shopping was then, as is traditional,
a good partner for that now you say yourself
do you also have companies or partners customers of
the men for you from your point of view who make
more than a billion in sales it is
something completely different when you had the shop
that makes so much sales  Is it
at all possible for you
both target groups say the small
shops that are just starting and the huge
shops to service both together cleanly
and
that was actually one of the
main reasons why
I even made snow devils myself back
then because I did back then
really asked around and said
we have people have now huh  lt ok if
you then start to open a business
then you do it best
with the open source software and then
if that works well then
sell it on ebay and then later
egs will call it somehow and they will author it
you add your whole
retail system to them and the fact that now and then you have
this idea that you should rebuild your entire system three
times four times five times as a growth company
sounds to
me like you somehow become
one into one  designer goes and says
i want to redecorate my house a bit
and say that building the house
and that is throwing away all the software
and using others
is an incredibly difficult topic
at all even by the sch haye it's
a giant it's almost impossible that
is  Making software that
really has scalability over the
entire lifespan of people in the
business is because I'm scared
important and the only reason why we did it
before while the industry
did it differently in my opinion
it was simply
because making the easy software
if you know exactly you are your customer
because if you don't know exactly who the
customer is then  it's just there you have to make
b very, very flexible and very
simple software that just that
the big problems of the the knight is
simplified that's more difficult but
that's exactly what i did and that's why
i talk a lot about the entrepreneurs
because that's really them  Entrepreneurs are the ones
who have done a lot for the economy but we want to stick with them
for the applies to
overall growth we don't want to
use any other software then
if you want to use it in another hope
that's okay too we have a
lot of people  who will go at some point and
use something like demand who because
they heard somewhere at the conference
that this is for their g  big ones now is
what they should use and then
at some point or somehow
build something new magento on magento but in
almost all cases they come back of course
at some point just note how
many problems are already ready for you
solved how much faster and scalable
and such  should i say that it is
natural because the story is of
course we are very happy
about it and because it suits us in that we had
since the software started
a short break for our popular
series people we actually
would have met at the air festival the
a series of times the colleagues
from media impact started with axel springer
stefan mühling carsten schwecke and i
wanted to hear back in how things are going at the
moment so karsten means
carsten schwecke from william
egmond haidt philipp christ as the last time
you spoke there  tells you that
you are actually getting through the crisis quite well
and that's still the case
maybe a follow-up question what
role does the Bavarian
controversial flagship die bild
absolutely so honestly if you
look at the numbers i
think everything about the classic marketing
environment has been between minus 30 and
minus 50 percent, especially as far as the
last two to three months are concerned
we are much better there and precisely
because of will because of image so image is
really the medium of the brand that
continues to attract enormously but all of them say they
followed you meet
because of the political line so
that you
would even destabilize democracy would have an inciting
radicalization effect  these topics do
you also encounter this in the advertising market so crisis
there questions like the ignition
so there are certainly one
or the other who
feels the need to express themselves and b is of
course always a much-loved topic in
the twitter bubble but  when we get to the
actual core you just have to
try it  say that's really
completely different aren't exactly the
opposite it's right what is the
job of journalism but it has to
ask exactly the critical
questions you shouldn't want the population to
be a yes and now the
picture is big and the picture is allowed too  being
criticized and if bild also
makes mistakes then we also have to be addressed, so to speak
, but
all in all you have to say the whole great
reporter performance right now on the subject of
black lips meters or if you
look at what we have done on the
subject of child abuse in the last few days  So,
as the father of three core areas, you directly
say an important topic that is then all
quickly left out in the popular
twitter tweets and that, in
my opinion, is a bit too short,
but there are the first companies that
say they are pausing their budgets on
facebook because  if you don't agree with the line
, you do it that way
at the end of the day  here also for
you about business and marketing the
depth of detail and advertising memory in
social media has a definite
attention deficit that you come in
all studies the clear comes from social
media can only scratch the
surface look at our fast
switching duration for all
classic media ever  The more intensively the
content is consumed, the
higher the advertising recall is, by the way, not
only for the image that applies to all
classic bindings. I was able to bind the advertising
impact enhancer
would like to write his e-mail address
is carsten punkt schwecke schwecke with
ck edh axel springer punkt something comes up
that I should notice which
I think is also hopefully from
his point of view an important observation
is that you have actually grown very strongly over
the years thanks to
influenza and  tank thanks to instrument
face  book because a lot of people who
now had reach via this
platform, let's say starting with the
kardashians here, I really think I
also want to work with your system and
then sell a lot of products
because they suddenly
have the reach, they say now I'll make my
own  make up my own whatever
and then they look for a place where they
can sell it and then
somehow now over the years all the
successful influenza always shopping
figs was something or we had to record the
podcast the obvious
remote team canada and exactly  at
this point we had very brief
sound problems we only cut out a few seconds
which was hardly
audible and actually the
right woman is only now coming in and coming back
we live in a time when its team
edition was in  the media and
in this intermediate it just
happened that the people go directly  en the
kardashians don't need a lobby have set up
their own nike like
kylie jenner has built up her own lipstick and
then i think i have
i don't know the numbers are enough
but
it has sold 50 percent of it a short time ago
was even  everything
but
that was built up within a few
years and she has her own
reach and she does
n't have to share it with anyone and
we're seeing stories like that more
and more now that it for us that
the people with reach  the thieves are
using it now instead of that now well
i grew up with
michael schumacher advertises for
mcdonald's the german nancial consultancy
think I
would say exactly like that yes the thief had
that had the michael metter of Vermögensberatung
structures that is that
is who he has  he used his
reach to make money
by actually doing nonsense
ha  t so that every estate
didn't know that he wouldn't leave it himself
now people use this
to make
products diddy diddy extend their range pauli
has for parts were the lips the
libdems lipstick industry about perfect
that was has exactly to her  bryant
therefore fit the program
and the connections
her fans had with her through these
products has been increased and that
is a much much better
organization of this case found with
all these things must and that the
emirate found on our platform  now
you have to convince them or how
did that happen to all these people years ago, so to speak,
when infra, when the whole
business -influenza business at all
beginners instagram became so relevant
that the all shops follow we would have
yes there were others too so you are not
monopolist
you almost pretended you
somehow steered him there somehow did
marketing with him ge  talked
or can it be that way by coincidence
kylie rated herself for a basic account
for 29 dollars per month basic account
on two very warmly
that has nothing to do with inference so
we have that happened because
of products that is of
course we have again
we were lucky again
but we have so we work
a different quality of products every day
that that's just easy
to use and that's just better
and that's just has a good reputation and
says if you have a torso sticks out what you
should use  hopefully people will say that the shop should use it
because of the quality of the
product
but that didn't bother me
after all that happened we of
course rolled out the red carpet
and we had a
lot of super interesting
meetings with the kardashian
strategy  talked about what how you can
build it up now how you can
bring it internationally and should
say the h  we also helped them with the
information they needed
and we do that with others too,
we then went all the way into the
mbc program for five people with such a
background and then
people talked about it and then it
went on like this, of course, but it
really did  that it didn't even
start yourself you're the biggest
beneficiary of influenza marketing in
the world probably in the end
i don't
think so but think about it switzerland
probably created less value
with it than now that you're the biggest
fans in the world so or  one of the
biggest ones are likely to have created significantly less
value than you did in
the last five years,
so if you play with me the
paper money with the media shares something like
that, then maybe you
really play in hard cash or no
circumstances but
that but that  is of course also the
difference between if almost sold
then it is then sell you create  st
the object if he is with company
valuation it is this net present value
calculation which of course works completely differently
meanwhile there is also i think
i even saw the tesla shop
so if you buy a car then it can
also be processed with you if  you
don't buy the car the excessive restore is
for for tesla is used creator
or at least has i'm i'm not quite i
have yes i think so but definitely
for spacex too
but that's also selling cars but
about the users in he can for that car
reservations the use of
of concept is very very diverse as
I said are very flexible platform tell
me how many how many shops you
currently have online so
regularly or take action a
little more to the millions
there were in the world and in
175 countries yes and  then which ones in the
metrics do you look at the most ala
market value spoken out now
but so the shops wi  e many shops are
online and then there are not
all pay the same for
logically I've seen
a metric, so to speak, found
it exciting you do but in sales they say in
Germany then the sales which in the
end you can't keep but
your own, so to speak  sales are
not processed through you, but
remain with pv for
all your direct costs afterwards, so to speak, and so that
's about a billion now,
so in
terms of sales it's about a billion a week for those who
sell to our customers
and the company  turnover is one and a half
weeks last year was one and a half
billion
and but the the values i look at ar
the three numbers the i
ea is how many sell so how m
ch sell our customer data i see
that as i said our product is us
d for that it's about such
things sell
how much how many active
customers sell at
least weekly  tens a product and
then like today so how long does it take
so how many seconds are there
between now people have their first
sale those are the three numbers
no longer look at those those are good
numbers if you all go if the
annual direction then  is
our company doing well and is the
customer doing well too and it is important
that the relationship between company has
its own customers as if they were on
the same side is setting the table
what you have now seen through
you have now  so to speak
, we have just described hate for years
you have so to speak made it still today
he is also offering the software
so that other people can sell something
but you will now also
be in the videos you area so
now people should also download expensive euros
and then you want to
help your partners sell directly through
your apple because that's a
little bit actually right now  t a Beatles
settlement twice around the back again
you can say that
because see about advance if it
works then yes but of
course that is still quite new
here we would like to
do everything we can think of and
to help our customers  to
sell more
whether that means that we help them
to sell on facebook or instagram
or whether that means that he
offers the cash register system so that they
can use it in the store or whether that means that
we
try to dismantle the four
downloads so that the customers can do
it
could sell more to their existing customers and
can sell again and stuff like that that
's the category of products that we
make and yeah that's exactly what we've
learned recently that you're
quite happy
with water now in the first shop that that's relatively good
month a bit earlier in a mood that
actually wanted because of
course we are now in this k  rise are
and we
normally would have
probably launched it towards the end of the year but it
's a little earlier endeavor
should be able to help
with sales should help with sales
and that's
incredibly important now because as I said it
's mainly a lot of our dealers
resident shirt then you have to
close the animal shop that so far has mainly been
germany of course it is
now slowly being opened again
but above all in many countries
the rest of the world for a
complete relaxation and to help them
with the digital cs it was
scary  important that means, so
to speak, is an app that you can
now download under and then
you will find there in the app that you
provide almost all the products of your
from the companies that use your shopping
right, so to speak, and above all
have those of them  you've already bought
the best is if you if you if
you now what we're good m  with him he uses
then you can give us the release
mix and then then
let me show you all the
stuff you bought you think about
doing the package trekking for you and
let's tell exactly where your packages are and
when you were back  want to buy from
one of all the companies that found the
animals you have already bought from them
than then you
can easily do that and to
other that is a features as well as
such features are in the
eshop that is just simple  shop just
like our ticker symbol together
a few words always plays
with the concert of the really, really
big digital companies in the world, so to speak,
many say yes, okay, in the e-commerce
sector there are now two relevant
platforms amazon anyway and now your
amazon is all over  apparently
totally customer-oriented, jeff bezos also says
that what counts in the end is what the customer, i.e. the end customer, ultimately counts for
want to have it is a problem for
you your end customer is not the end customer at all
but that your end
customer is a retailer and that you, so to speak, you have such
a retailer perspective and amazon
actually the the better customer you can be
so many days
that we
are  important that every company knows for
whom silver builds software and
if you
can lose that then because then
the company cannot relatively
easily go the wrong way in the rain a
well-known example here
in canada is  blackberry
many in germany don't have the right of way over the iphone
themselves on around the
world they have blackberry
smartphones
and but at some point blackberry might
be forgotten your customers
were they negotiated so much with the
network
operators that at some point you just did
exactly that  the
network operators wanted to do it and
somehow lost their connection
to her  en end customers
then they didn't build the iphone
but
made the blackberry that's
a problem that many companies
have all the time for us it's very
important that we made that
decision and we're going to find out now if
that was the right decision  in the
end it's or or or not
and we don't care either we don't have one it
's not important to us to make the biggest company in the
world
originally i wanted to make the world's best 22
people company is an original
idea
what we wanted to do is we just want to
be right  have a really, really
good product and if people
find it valuable then the
company is valuable that's okay the idea
is that we think
dealers are
much more important even to the customers are
much more important than now the
internet which the original ideas from
the internet is said to have brought here the
dealers are the ones who invent the
products the hands are the products  in different
ways i have a
connection with many many products
and many dealers many brands but
directly
and that for me as a customer that is
actually the right thing that
the dealers can present themselves
as they want and if they to many
dealers  when the new product
comes out which i don't think at all
what that actually fits the
brand
suddenly because i know the retailer and
they get this this that i
trust the hat
i also buy the product from them
and that's the decision  those
affected have
amazon
really only acted on the product,
that means it doesn't matter who the retailer behind the
product is making the product, they
show whatever the
price is usually the lowest
of the category, which is usually then made
by them themselves
and
that is that is a different
approach to the same topic and i would have
times that in the end for the
products that you really need,
amazon's approach is probably better,
so i'm going to say that none
of our customers will ever beat that
in the toilet paper category
,
but the things you
have right are often much
more than these  supported by the dealer
these are the small
dealers the medium-sized companies and so on you have an
exchange with jeff bezos from time to time
is it ever more regular e-mails
telephone or something like that or not at all not
regularly never but from time to time it
has happened would be okay  and you
respect each other so first
you get dressed obviously he has to
yes
ca
n't be sure is
in any case not particularly happy
about the way in which the job is presented
free and amazon difference in the
press then
not necessarily have either  helped in the last
few years
but i would be so i respect but
i think amazon is probably the one
best the best company in the world depending
on how you
look at it but so from the capitalist
shareholder was in value is there is
no better company than amazon likes to believe better
managed company than amazon mine with
my way according to my conviction
but i am me me  think it would be a
shame if only amazon existed on the
internet it is very important to us that
we give the small dealers the same advantages, so to speak,
that amazon has built for
itself and
so we see ourselves in the end of the world
and a little bit more  what you say about facebook
or or or as instagram above all
with whom you have
already discussed the history that we have
just discussed and
you have now
expanded new cooperations seems as
if you are now exchanging more deeply there
and  there is another relationship with them
because because facebook and
doppelpfeil have a lot in common over the years  enworked and
so
were mainly used together by our customers
because you have an
apple store
so quality is never an issue, for
example they had opened up twice as much, put
their products on it and then
they advertised their products on instagram
and instagram ore that is  as a result,
customers of facebook probably stopped their products
and probably with
other facebook ore too and so on
and this cooperation of
schierke fixed in the facebook advertising
platform has done an enormous amount for this
direct consumer wave that bhc and
now especially have in the last
year  we really put our
heads together and say instead of
people celebrating individually and so
individually so do it while shopping
and then do it on
facebook if we now want to solve this special
situation from the point of view of the product
, which, like before, is
only halfway in  facebook shops have
come up that you can stop directly from
shops  can operate and that is now
a new product what do i do when the
calves have announced and
that is running here that will get that out now
that is just still in m access but
i would have that becomes a relatively important
factor of the knight value and that makes
where  someone else picks up that
you would like to make a phone call and
think about it so we can
meet you or what do you think? yes that
is so we have
at some point of course it was difficult
with the calendar but at some point
we just have to  did they bring out the excavator
and
shoveled out the appointment calendar
and then we talked about one day
and said here is my world
is yours how does it look like you heard
what you heard in
california how is
the water running  in that case it was in
california where we
did it but it goes both ways
and if i hear it now and you
can on twitter  follow extremely well
until he is very active on twitter, for example
, then he has the feeling that
this whole active
think this whole capitalist and soy cash that is actually
i can do your world you do that should be fun
you just have such a great idea and
then has  tell me you somehow
slipped in so i'll tell you now what
can he not quite be forest for that it's
too blatant but it seems a bit
like that and if you
follow it from a german point of view or a lot of the press he likes it he says
is seen completely differently so he is
really accused of
risking the overall social health of the world
with facebook and thus all the fake
news stories because she was seen are not two
completely different personalities you and he,
for example
, all all people  are different
all people have different
things the problems they have to deal with
so i
say yes i
would  I say do it the way
you do it probably isn't enough but
I think that now it's
just a big is a big and
important discussion we have I
would have I'm of the
opinion that social media is more
given that's one of  these
things that that it wasn't built that
's that iss is that's a better
word in English that discovered that's
like that that that it's always been there
and that that was lying around somewhere and
someone found out and that
was ten  other social network
came before says hans built 11
but facebook has become the big one and
the advantages are relatively clear but in
cooperates in all sorts of new the
individual we now think about the world
so all of a
sudden i can start new snowboard grant tomorrow
and  can directly find the people who will have
exactly the snowboard i kind of have
snowboards now with
some kind of technology
set up and i can find exactly the people
who like early access
diddy diddy technology
and who like snowboarding and i can then
find them directly and i don't have to somehow
sell to procter gamble or sell june
live with it because they have aldi
television advertising sports i can
now carries  my customers find
the fantastic world because half is
half and one employee but
for small companies small companies and
that's important that they exist and
that they survive and that's one
thing things are done
again the other thing is the social
media  power is a huge
1 1 1
huge mirror to show the world well
and we just don't look old
but we just don't like everything you
see and
that's a huge difficult topic making
water about it how do you act what
updates man and that it's now
max  job to improve that because the
situation at the moment is just
not what we want
one
a  In another time it would be what is what, what
the politicians have to
explain, would have to clarify exactly and
now it's running that
we don't live in a time like this, we don't have to now
that people make small improvements
you think it's right, so say somehow
you explained to me, he'll get it  he
is obviously sufficiently smart and
also motivated to solve it
yes i had i could have been much
much much worse
an offer or a principle that
i didn't know at all comes from
the german kreditbank ag the
dkb you start at the very beginning  what do
banks do with our money they
continue to invest it to earn money themselves
then the money is often invested in nuclear
or coal-fired power plants or even in wild
speculation on the stock exchange of course the dkb does not do any of that, but rather
it is aimed very explicitly at
sustainable projects and has a total of
over 50 billion in volume in
projects that somehow make the world a better place
so make affordable and clean
energy health and well-being
education or justice that is more than
80 percent of what the bank actually has from deposits
they call themselves
the money improvers and
want to say that you participate and
also open an account with the dkb because
then the money is automatically used immediately to
make the world a better place and
can only make the world a better place with a car account, so to speak, without leading
thun
that's the patch from
the dkb just take a look and
improve money punkt dkb punkt.de
and tell me the last one  maybe a founder
with whom you always interact a bit
because he's also a
big figure in germany it's all
masc because the innkeeper is of course also
very strongly noticed here because he
attacks the car industry and
does various other things and you
always have such encounters
I've already spoken to him about tesla that
you have certain products  offers the job
but recently there was an
online opportunity to
donate to the nation so in
the end you donated exactly 1 1 dollars through more
than a mask and that makes you feel like
you also have such a special
relationship is right that
i it depends  to the reactions to
so
a lot of respect
at least from me to him no idea
how he thinks of me but
is one of the most interesting people in
the world and i do
it better i wish the
the car industry had the country a
bit better  one categorized that
was all unfortunately that's a pity
it went that way i know that a
few pretty good
electric cars have been built now but that
's that i have unfortunately with my
distance from canada it's a bit easier every now and then
about its entire
industry  looking at it i thought it was
a bit of a shame it's important
that people would notice more quickly
that the testers were there  s are
actually a computer on wheels
and that this will bring about a
lot of changes in the
industry now it's late but nothing
to repeat but not too late
not too late already the
the the trust that people have in these the
german car brands but in the  rest of
the world is incredible 55 someone who
emigrated from germany this is
the total trust in german
engineering being german in the gutter
rest of the world is massively underestimated
by people who live
in germany and grow up in germany that is the
problem is that you can do that in
just don't really explain germany to anyone because
it's a bit
like explaining water table somehow now
but outside of germany it's
really enormous it's an enormous factor
or it's very important i would have it will
work but i need it  i
need it takes a bit a
generation to wander we mu
we don't have to say they don't have to give the danes the
title car companies for the
generations if i leave that to the baby boomers that's one thing
that's starting right
now that's an important thing about the changeover
you also have a bit
more patting native there you have
sometimes in direct contact with your us tour
trigger exchanges very little
about one thing that i
find interesting about you you are the coo of
his huge company and yet
you have the time from time to time do you
do gaming challenges or post is also
with  twitter about the fact that you somehow
play online games and stuff up to
your knees but the feeling you've remained a big
boy who then
somehow I want to gamble and that
actually shares everything there and that's how it is
with you simply because I'm up for
it  or does
it have to do with philosophy or how come i'm just not
i am i'm 16 years old actually
who loves his life but
it's just like that  that you have fun with
it and then there is no one who
says then just do it i would have that
is one as i said that the topic of the
world is direct to consumer actually
that is not the right word but it
is we are all directly connected and
the world of the last 100 years was
a production of pa companies
and institutions and incredibly
influential giant companies
more than that should say now
if you tried to put a new product
into the world
in the eighties where i was a child in
germany  english team follow everyone
and could marco transformers
get into these apple sports
that we saw back then
they were all pre-sold
the idea they bought three
companies that is detergent and
so procter gamble matter and bassist
and a few others
there was no
way to see new products directly because there was no
way better quality toys
to do because the ones who sold
themselves when the one could follow into those 30
seconds of the 10 second spot into the
wealth and that
's exactly the same for the rest of the world
now we have connections and direct
to people and I have I have
no one i don't feel like opening a pr agency
to say how i should be
what kind of person now i am
also i am i like video games i used to be
kiteboarding i don't like skateboarding i don't
like
traveling i like mine i love my
children i am i find  technology is crazy
and exciting and great and sometimes
problematic and then there are problems
that have to be solved and i find the
process of companies building
companies to these i also find it
incredibly interesting and i just share that
but people find them interested
and interesting then that's the bread
and then not if that's okay with us, too.
now, as a marketing guy, of course I have to
ask a question, because
whenever you don't  hts sees you have a
sun in germany you will say
flat cap on your cap traded every time
and saw us on
google here in the factory and that you are up
again is that somehow a
bit of a brand building gimmick
or that so in love with this kind  and
useful and nobody what several of them
well i got away with it i have that's
my haircut
that's how i think about it i at some
point i decided well i
said at some point you at some point my wife
here and i said that somehow
have to somehow
have to  kinda like bringing hats back
hut were awesome were good
product is were kinda is like
when you have no
individuality at all eventually you can
buy any other watch which of course can be nice
but that also has all sorts of
statements about you and i need
my apple bot  so that's
kinda my wrist is gone now and
then to wear a chain like that  it's not
my thing but and well i can wear
i've decided exactly and
the zis did you like it every day
what is every day with the videos with you
with barack obama or something and whatever
the hat whatever
but let's say  Another topic
that I'm also currently
he is an important topic in the world home
office and you can have a strong
opinion on one and said somehow you still
believe in the permanent home
office
I would have that the disco will
be brought forward in 2030 to 2020 and that
all sorts of changes that we have
slowly seen in the world,
so above all the
digitization of the world should just
happen a lot faster
now than before and
one of the things that
has always happened in the world is that
that that  the work in the office
happened and
no one can go to his office anymore
so as i said i am here in
north america in germany it's a
matter  n really different germany
treated the corvette situation is also incredibly good gave i
hope like i said that’s the way fischer that
’s something to do with the fish so that
i will there’s an awful lot of criticism
but
from the outside perspective that’s really it
’s really  no country that is that
or at least no geographic
regions the
comedy has been handled better
and as a
result many things are slowly opening up
but of course the situation that
is opening up is different than the
situation we left this this idea
that working in the office happens for
companies  how our how we really do all
our work digitally on the
computer i think it will come back
i would have that we would have to do the work
digitally by default
i mean that we can really work together
from
anywhere and that
now especially that  people work
together in a room
without being opposed to others in any way
will be transferred or that's actually
a problem is in the end teamwork i
have it's a situation that i'll
come back that means we're going to
rebuild our offices a lot, which
we're going to do
that we're going to be the office is
on bmw's s the german word, so to speak
for berns this is the
acceleration lane but also
to bring singer around on boarding autobahn
exactly that is that the office is actually
a feeder to the digital world
just like the home office and so
we will build the car we will
not open our office at all in 2020
they will reopen,
we will continue to open, but
we will have a different floor
plan and try to convert relatively
quickly to this in the future, which we
think will come to all or many of
us, because I
would like that
that is that there are three ways there are
these means you all have all the people
in the same room that is  the best thing is you
have all the people who are digital in their
own box in a zoom or
something that's good too and then you
have this hybrid middle thing where
a few people are clearing out a few
people are digital and I think that's
the worst of  everyone and that's why
we're just trying to have a stronger
opinion on it they are we did it
again very briefly was that the last
cooperation we did now that was
bigger is that also a key thing
that you're building so big with walmart this year
that that  will the
year be shaped even more that people think from the
outside i have the so smooth
brewing water only then was there also a lot of
discussion in the english press is
the shaping it's just one of
many yes i think that's that's one
of judge that  is like i said
it is what
you have today incredibly
strong infrastructure a wool market is
i think 30 minute
drive from something like 300 400
million  en people
and there I have to do together
for all the small dealers who of
course now want this digital
native direct to consumer business who
have they simply make the best and
the most interesting products and
doing that together could of
course become one very, very well  a lot that
still needs to be done a lot that
needs to be continued but that's
just that the great thing we can do with
schoppe drivers is the
tde to get this mass of little butts
together and to represent almost like a
trade union halfway
to that company  like facebook or
hardware store because that's how you get many, many,
many small things together
you have a very, very big deal if
you put all of tores shops in america together
it's the second largest payer after
amazon
and that way we can
negotiate things and in the factories  who are
completely different are what the
class could do themselves based on that
is no that  is a part of jobs
that i find incredibly exciting
and hopefully very valuable
it will lead to the
small dealers
being able to become as successful as they can be that
you are still in contact with germany a lot
at all so just look
do you speak a lot in german or do you still have many
contacts in germany
i stopped
reading the north american press i only look
at the left at some point and worry
otherwise consumed with huge mirrors
and stuff like that what i now
just think that i find now and
the  guardian and a condom they're the
ones against i'm
now also looking at europe for my
news because that's just not there
we still have proper journalism in
europe and that's important ok and
friends or or parents and so
probably my parents are in
german-speaking countries  my mother is
now a presence in austria and
my family still lives in  koblenz
and i come there normally but in
normal years i get there i
mean i have three
children three boys and m10 and younger and
i usually go on a trip with
them through germany
once a year and
i like to do things like that you will
only join me  of bavarian politics so
german founders
german politicians ask you for advice if you are
now again from a german
perspective one of the most successful
even better networked people
ever then you should ask his
female economics minister in the
chancellor company
even talk again  and is there anything who knows more about
the message but not yet
but I would like to have I
would love to have more contact although
I don’t necessarily want to spend
more time with
politics now of course I have
this cockpit tracing off in
the districts in germany were made by sap
i think and that  telecom and
in canada we did this hobby driver
and blackberry together
so now i had a lot more with the politicians
at least in the
english speaking area and thats
enough for me for a while now
[laughter]
you do it yourself you do you do a
lot  thoughts about it i'm going to drive now it
was of course such a
fantastic or crazy situation
is that the duo in this would have
to say this paper prosperity do you have you my
school friends or because you see your
parents that's unbelievable one is
really unbelievable that you to  a lot
and that's really complete so
unbelievable
what you've been working on makes
you think how could
I use that or or or are
you still trying to leverage it somehow or
you say hey that's just paper
and I'll watch myself  only liked it in the shop
yes i now look a little
beyond that i have it like i have
mine  e foundation founded with my
wife who has been special for a long time
decarbonization that is our topic
so with
environmental protection with you are special up to
now a bit more specialized
in how to really
remove carbon molecule from the from the out of the
air as they call it documents
that's what we call it but
that i've also in the in the
in the future that's starting right
now we have it when we as
foundations in the foundations is not
wanted so as a foundation has
deposits
okay okay so a bit  but now
it's going against a bit
more happened until now the last 15
years was shocked failla really
needed my total have well total time and now
i can look a little further
outside the box
okay okay awesome i'm very curious about
what's going on  now, of
course, I'm extremely happy to follow, somehow, of
course, so I think one can
also looking a little proud from
Germany that's pretty much as
possible it's just really
a crazy story and we've had a
lot of pretty crazy stories in the podcast for the last few years
that's the crass old home I think
thank you for going over the time a
bit  that the guest has a full
calendar there are other things to do
so carry
messages of slain fights for my
next meeting all the time i try that's the way
it was so many many thanks
tobi for the time and yes all the best
with the jockey party  and will be
back in germany at some point you're up to
something we're trying
to make that possible thank you
very much for doing it very well we'll do it again ok then we
'd love to happily ok
schotter see you again
before it's all over reference to our
sister portal finance for
we're not busy  only with digital business
digital marketing but also quite
explicitly  with finn tag and in the finance
business and my
editorial colleagues have of
course taken every angle of the wirecard
story in the last few days have once
reported internally how employees from
wirecard have experienced the last few days who
might buy the leftovers of wirecard
so what's on finance forward
there  there are articles every day and
a podcast every week finance fw de.com
this podcast is produced by
popstars
at mr